كما شاهدتني أتحرك تتجمع
بقوة ، وبما أن الشخص الذي قاد
الطريق في العديد من هذه القضايا كان
في طليعة ما كان رأيك كما
رأيت للتو هوليوود تحولت تمامًا
ليس فقط إلى نفسها ولكن أيضًا
أغلقت هذه الروح العميقة  - البحث عن
الأنشطة والسلوكيات وقد رأيناها الآن
في المجال السياسي مؤخرًا
في لندن رأيناها في المجال المصرفي ،
ما رأيك ، ما
آمله هو أن هذا سيجعلك
تعرف هذه الأصوات التي خرجت
إرادة  تتحول إلى أفعال فعلية
بحيث يتحول الغضب الذي نشأ إلى
فعل فعلي وأنت تعلم حتى نتمكن من
رؤية السياسات تتغير حتى نتمكن من
رؤية الأخلاق والمعايير الثقافية
مغروسة في الشركات التي لا
تسمح بحدوث هذه الأنواع من
الأشياء  عند هذه النقطة ، يريد الجميع أن يكون
هذا التغيير
دائمًا ليكون تغييرًا في طريقة التفكير وتغييرًا
ثقافيًا ، أو تغييرًا ثقافيًا ، هل يمكنني
أن أكون ساخرًا وأقترح أننا بحاجة إلى
توخي الحذر الشديد بشأن الأشخاص الذين يدفعون
تغيير الكلام ولكن لا شيء
يتغير حقًا تحته بالضبط لأنني
أعرف أنني أعتقد أننا نريد أن نرى أجرًا متساويًا
على سبيل المثال نريد أن نراه يغير
سلوكًا فعليًا نريد أن نرى الموارد
الموجهة نحو الضحايا لذلك في أجزاء
من العالم نرى النساء  اختراق
الأسقف الممزقة للزجاج والأجزاء الأخرى من
خلال المشاهدة والبيع في
أسواق العبيد الحديثة حتى تعرف أن
هناك الكثير الذي يجب القيام به
ووفقًا لآخر تقرير عالمي عن الفجوة بين الجنسين
بالمعدل الحالي
للتقدم ،  يستغرق منا
مائتان وسبعة عشر عامًا لتحقيق
التكافؤ بين الجنسين ، لذلك لدينا الكثير من العمل
للقيام به ، ولا يكفي الحديث عن
هذه الأشياء التي نحتاج إلى ترجمتها ،
نحتاج إلى الانتقال من كسر الصمت
إلى الإجراءات الفعلية الملموسة